after going through a horrible divorce
is Wendy Williams willing to walk down
the aisle again you may be surprised by
what she has to say
Edie she also sounds off about some
other famous folks making news because
you know what that's what Wendy Williams
knows best how you doing you know I
can't talk to you and not itchy with
some hot okay Kristin Cavallari and Jay
Cutler announced that they are getting
divorced after they had been in the
Bahamas kicking it she's accusing him of
merit misconduct your thoughts I think
there's a lot more to this story you
know he was a mr. mom I'm sure that he
misses being you know the big football
hero if we want to play like the man we
gotta play like the men so she's got
some alimony coming on
believe me you Kevin Frazier Luther as
for Harry and Megan ditching the
monarchy for Malibu confidentially
speaking I think they'll be divorced
within three years really she wants to
be a Malibu girl she got what she wanted
you know the crown and the jewelry and
that kind of stuff and he misses London
and he misses home and maybe he's not
the Hollywood guy that she thought that
he was Wendy's own personal life has
become a hot topic during quarantine
three months after finalizing her
divorce from a husband of 22 years Kevin
hunter men are asking her out the wazoo
then I did not have back then and and I
have clarity like I've never had before
I definitely want a new mister yeah that
but I want him to be smart enough to
still tell me no Wendy now you sit down
I got this I'll take a ring on it
oh yeah with a prenuptial agreement but
you would walk down the aisle again oh
no
aisle there's no aisle I'm not wearing
that stupid white dress Kevin but is
Wendy a homosexual like Ellen who
interviews Andrew tomorrow on her show
people are saying there como sexuals
yeah I think that's a good thing I don't
think it's a bad thing I have to put the
TV on mute and watch them all day Chris
is married so I can't bother with him I
love them
Wendy's apartment in New York Wendy's
taping her show from home doing her own
hair makeup and wardrobe it's inspired a
new segment which is just Wendy eating
quirky food Wendy Williams has ascended
to a level not given that no human has
ever achieved before time John Oliver is
a new huge fan of yours
he's got taste it really does feel good
you know all I can ever be is me you
build something special Oh Wendy you
know tell me what you think I don't have
a tissue and don't mistake my tears for
sadness just actually for happy and joy
we really do have the best
behind-the-scenes production going on TV
I know that me and my people we're all
right
[Music]